faced the bullpen last night they faced
walker bueller tonight who shut him down
last saturday seven it names just one
run and over his last seven starts in
omar he's given up a total of six runs
yeah he's been outstanding all year long
and really when the daughters need him
and big big gains you know he's come
through we've seen them in the
postseason
2-2 from bueller is a fastball hitting
the ground to second trey turner's there
for the first down of the night
chopper turner again busy start
two out
pete alonso coming up at 2 56 26 home
runs and 69 runs batted ends uh 2-2
there's a ground ball to third
backhanded by turner throws across the
diamond
and a one two three inning for walker
mueller the run so hit star there's
nobody left will go to the bottom of the
first well carrasco his last time out
against the dodgers
only a couple of innings and six hits
and six runs three home runs all off
different pitches
obviously looking to get a better start
this time around he's got to establish
the fastball but the slider's got to be
sharp and in the zone because this
dodgers team as we talked about is very
very patient
and again are you kidding me
he's gonna push the envelope throw his
high
bounces by third turner stays at second
with a lead off double breaking ball
inside out swing and i think once turner
went to the bag he hooked his hand
around the bag slid past the bag and he
was not about to
loosen the grip on on the bag at all and
not aware that the ball had gone well
past the bag muncie was held in check
last night a rare old for four 3-2 on
the way and it's lifted out to center
field nemo has it lined up turner
tagging at second nimmo's got it turn
her heads to third the throw from nimmo
comes up short so it's a productive out
for muncie getting turner over to third
with one away here's justin turner
turner one for three last night
bouncing ball left side will bring home
trey turner and for the second
consecutive night they get him over and
get him in and it's one nothing here in
the first this is why situational
hitting is so important doesn't
necessarily take a hit to knock you in
it just takes good base running it takes
good you know at bats putting the ball
in play can't have the swing and misses
in those critical moments
corey seeger lofts a fly ball to left
field where gardena's dominic smith is
there to make the catch and that will
end the inning
one run one hit one nothing dodgers
after one now are stepping in with 14
home runs knocked in 31 switch hitter
batting from the left side there's a
strikeout he dialed it in there didn't
he back footing a slider grooving a fast
ball and then
striking him out there on three pitches
patrick mazeka coming up left-handed
hitting catcher he's nine for 32 one and
two to mazeco with conforto leading off
second davis off first call strike three
and that will end the inning so the vets
get first and second nobody out and come
up with nothing
buys the first pitch into center field
off the end of the bed it's gonna dunk
in for a base hit a couple soft hits for
turner tonight but line drives in the
box score and he's two for two the
outfield was playing him so deep routine
fly ball to left center but dominic
smith was way
way back
and nimo and center was even further
back max looking for his first hit of
this series hole for five
muncie yanks a line drive to right field
a base hit that bounces by conforto to
the wall
watch trey turner race around the bases
and make it to nothing on a double from
max muncie hits a ball to the wall
that's all it takes for trey turner to
be able to score from first next muncie
does a great job getting the barrel of
the ball that's on the top of the zone
hitting that double muncie is second
justin turner at first seeger rips the
line drive base it pass to diving mcneil
muncie in the score and it's three
nothing on a seeger base hit
first pitch off-speed pitch and for
seekers stayed right on top of it stays
on it puts a great swing
drives it up the middle rbi fourth
inning pete alonso leads off against
walker bueller gets first pitch breaking
ball and lofts it out to right center
deep back goes bellinger and it's out of
here that ball had carried to it out to
right center field just over the wall
and pete alonso has his 27th home run of
the year to get the mets on the board
wow well i guess you got to be pete
alonso and hit the ball over 100 miles
an hour like he did last night to cut
through that thicker la air because that
looked like it was just going to be a
little gapper slider out over the plate
first pitch half swing
and pete is so strong seven straight
retired by carrasco since seeger's rbi
hit in the third and that brings up
justin turner grounded on the left side
vr
gets in front of it throws out justin
turner and carlos carrasco retires eight
in a row to complete five innings for
the first time this year two out of four
coming up a 1-2
ground ball
short right backhanded by trey turner
the shift was on and it paid off
conforto retired another one two three
inning for mueller he's retired 11 in a
row since the homer in the single from
alonso and conforto in the fourth
jonathan vr who has struck out twice on
change-ups
the 2-2 vr
a little pop-up in the short left field
sprinting in is taylor to make the catch
and that'll end the unit smooth sailing
for uh walker bueller pete alonzo with a
home run and the first pitch of the
fourth that's the lone blemish against
walker bueller who's gone seven and a
third twice this season but not deeper
than that
big breaking ball gets him swinging
good pitch by walker bueller to come
back get that
that strikeout right after that lead off
base hit so now basic could tie the game
mizeka third nimo the tying run at
second with one out
and he takes on the inside corner flings
his back in anger at the call by nestor
ceja the pitch appeared to be inside
seija calls him out and that is a huge
call for the second out of the inning
mueller got the call for his eighth
strikeout and now has an exit ramp to
this inning as he takes on lonzo who
took him deep back in the fourth 2-0
coming from bueller and he bounces one
slowly toward third tough play for
turner and he won't make a throw the run
scores and it's a one-run game
second infield hit of the inning dave
roberts calls down to the pen lot of
emotion packed into this eighth inning
and so the time run at third the go
ahead run in scoring position for jd
davis
[Applause]
he is screaming clinching his fists as
he walks off the field two out azekah is
one for three in a run scored
good morning good afternoon good night
and a 3-2
exactly what the dodgers needed they
needed him to go deep in the game once
again comes up big